Hey, it's me Destin, welcome
back to Smarter Every Day.
I love,
laminar flow.
And people send me tweets
about laminar flow,
all over the internet, its time to do,
the laminar flow video.
Check this out, big pool.
We're going to see if we can
make, laminar flow happen.
I should be able to poke
a hole, in this pool,
and get a glassy looking jet,
that comes out this pool.
That's what laminar flow is.
It's very orderly, looks like glass.
Okay, so here we go, ready,
three, two, this feels so wrong.
Let's see if we get laminar flow,
no, we don't.
(laughs)
Now I've got a hole in a pool.
Okay, laminar flow is
a function of geometry,
obviously I had the wrong geometry.
We're going to try a
big spike, here we go.
Oh golly.
Okay.
(Laughs)
Alright.
No, it doesn't work.
So my shape's not right.
My shape's not right, what do I do.
Work, work, work, work with me.
Ah, there we go, okay, so.
I got laminar flow right here,
and its going turbulent, right here.
Why?
Laminar flow is a function of
the geometry, the velocity,
and the kinematic viscosity,
of the fluid that you're working with.
Right now, my velocity,
is not fast enough,
to have laminar flow, because
there's not enough pressure,
so if I move it down, I
should have more pressure.
So, let's plug this back up,
well now I have a problem.
That's out.
I'm doing a bad job of
explaining laminar flow,
what we need to do, we need
to go, around the world,
to different places I've
observed laminar flow
in the past several years.
And we need to let me
show you, various things
that I've seen along the way.
Laminar flow is orderly, all
streamlines are parallel,
and there's no mixing of the flow.
It's all like how you would imagine,
water flowing through pipe,
everything is straight and parallel.
Turbulent flow however, is chaotic,
there's pressure fluctuations throughout,
you get the idea.
Engineers have this special term,
called the Reynolds Number.
To try and help predict,
what type of flow,
they might be dealing with.
The top of the equation are the things
that describe the flow itself,
like the velocity, the
density, the geometry, etc.
But the bottom of the equation
is viscosity of the fluid.
Like how thick the fluid
is, like water vs honey.
A lower Reynolds Number,
means that the flow is more laminar,
and in my opinion, more awesome.
But a high Reynolds Number
means that it's more turbulent.
So if you look at the equation,
you can kinda see what's going on here.
If you have more viscosity,
that means Reynolds Number gets smaller,
therefore the flow is more laminar.
But if you increase the
velocity of the flow,
or the size of the flow,
Reynolds Number gets bigger,
therefore you have more turbulent flow.
If you keep Reynolds Number
and the mock number the same,
you can make a model of
whatever you're trying to fly,
and you can get a good idea
if turbulence or laminar flow
is going to happen over the model.
That's exactly what they
did with the Saturn V,
this is the big Saturn V right here.
But in order to approximate
what was going to happen,
they made a wind tunnel model.
You can use wind tunnel models,
like this little four inch model.
To approximate the flow, over
the entire, Saturn V rocket.
As flow comes through here,
and goes across this Apollo capsule,
if the string flickers as turbulent flow,
if it's steady, it's laminar flow.
Check this out.
(whirring)
So as we change the angle of attack,
you can see the different
types of flow, take place.
It's a little hard to see
it, with just the strings,
but Sarah-Kate, who goes
to school with my daughter,
made an awesome science fair project.
You've got to see this.
Okay, to demonstrate laminar
flow and turbulent flow,
this is Sarah-Kate, science
fair winner, extraordinaire.
Right,
- yes sir.
- [Destin] You going to
show us how it works?
So NASA Glenn Research Center,
and you just built it from the plans?
- Yes sir,
- [Destin] That's awesome.
- [Sarah-Kate] I had parental
supervision and guidance.
So you have to pick your scent.
- [Destin] Frankincense, dragons
blood, that's pretty legit.
Orange, that's got to be good.
That's a weird smell.
- [Sarah-Kate] Okay,
now I'll blow them out.
- [Destin] Okay, and so,
that's going to make
the smoke come through,
this pipe right here right?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yep.
Now I'll turn on the fan.
(fan whirs)
- [Destin] So got to get
the light correct, right?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yep.
- [Destin] Okay, so
that's pulling it through,
should we be able to see it, yet?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yeah,
you can already see it.
- [Destin] You can already
see, oh what the heck.
You sure can,
look at that.
Oh that's cool, look at that.
Okay, cool, so, laminar flow,
are the straight lines
that go across, correct?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yep.
- [Destin] So that's a
zero angle of attack?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yes.
- [Destin] So give me a
real high angle of attack.
There you go, look at that.
So we're getting flow separation,
along the backside here,
and we're getting turbulence
back in here right?
- [Sarah-Kate] Mm hmm.
Let's see.
- [Destin] This is like
the coolest science fair
project you've ever done?
- [Sarah-Kate] It's the
only science fair project
I've ever done.
(laughs)
- [Destin] Look at that
turbulence back there.
So ultimately, what were
you trying to learn here?
- [Sarah-Kate] Basically,
I was just trying to learn
more about, airflow shapes,
and flow separation, and stall.
And make a good visual
representation of all those things.
- [Destin] Well I think
you accomplished that.
Look, man, look a it from
this angle right here.
You can see, you can see
the separation back there.
Look at that.
That's a really good angle.
This is an awesome experiment.
Are you going, you're going
to regionals now right?
- [Sarah-Kate] Yes sir.
- [Destin] You're going to win.
Do it.
If you've ever been to
the Detroit airport,
there's an awesome fountain,
like right in the middle of
the whole concourse area.
And you can see laminar flow in action,
programmed with computers.
- [Destin] It's the awseomest fountain,
let's go look at it.
What do you call this flow?
That flow right there.
- Laminar flow.
- [Destin] What's it called?
- [Destin] Laminar flow,
some daddies don't teach their
kids cool words like this.
- Oh, I already know alias.
- [Destin] Yeah?
- And all that other stuff.
- [Destin] You don't appreciate this.
- I do.
- [Destin] You just don't, you
just don't appreciate, what.
You just don't appreciate laminar flow.
Let's go.
(phone buzzes)
Dude.
Did you get the funnel?
Yep, alright, so here we go.
Thank you.
Ow my finger.
Okay there we go.
This is a Go-Pro right?
So what's happening is,
the flow is going into the funnel,
and as the flow goes in there.
All of the streamlines of
the water, are lining up.
And so its flowing parallel right,
once you get all the flow
going in one direction.
You can divert the laminar
flow, and the streamlines,
stay in the same orientation.
So look, you can start
to make things like,
sheets you see that?
Look at that.
It's working.
That's got ridges on it.
(gasps)
Okay, look at this, so if you get
all the laminar flow
going in one direction.
You can put things that,
look at that it made a bubble.
Okay, you can make a sheet,
like a sphere, of laminar flow.
Okay, so there's a really
cool children museum,
in Chattanooga, that I found this,
and I put my phone up under it.
Look at that, I could put my head in that.
That is beautiful.
This is probably my
favorite kind of fountain.
And the cool thing about it,
is the flow rate at the
center has to be high enough,
so that, it's glassy,
like you have enough flow
to make a complete covering.
But it's not too high,
where you go turbulent at
this location right here.
Right there.
See it's wanting to go
turbulent, but it's not.
And as, the water, drops off.
There's enough volumetric flow,
to cover and make it glassy,
360 degrees here.
Which is awesome.
So what I'm going to do,
is put my phone in there,
and see if we can see
through the laminar flow.
Let's see if it's smooth enough.
Okay, you ready?
Another thing I like to think about,
is the inverse square law,
and the flow rate as it comes out.
Anyway here we go.
(muffled water flowing)
That works doesn't it?
So the next question is, can you hear me?
So it's totally engulfed with water,
I don't know if you can here me or not,
but the microphone is probably
full of water at this point,
but let's try this.
Can you hear me better now?
I like this a lot.
(water flowing)
I like that a lot, okay.
It's really fun, when you're
30 something years old,
and you have to wait
for the two year olds.
So you can do you're
little fluid experiment.
I love laminar flow, and
I want you to love it too.
Prince Rupert, you're in my light, move.
Thank you.
Okay, so, the thing that
I think is so neat here,
is if you think about
the volumetric flow rate,
if it's not enough,
you don't have water go
all the way to the bottom.
You see how it's breaking up here.
But, if you control all of
these variables, perfectly,
you can make a fountain
do exactly what you want.
This is beautiful.
I really respect people that
design fountains like this,
because it has to do with flow rate,
has to do with, pressure,
the nozzle geometry.
Anything, can disturb, the flow.
- [Destin] It's amazing
watch, touch it, come here.
- [Woman] Oh, it's shot, it's up,
are we going to go up, and then down?
- [Destin] Yeah, touch it, touch it.
- Are we allowed to touch this?
- [Destin] Well we're doing it.
Ah that's so stinking cool,
I love it.
You know why I love it?
Laminar flow.
Can you imagine they had
to perfectly level this,
because that's gravity fed.
And then you have to make sure the flow,
into the orifice there, is perfectly
perfectly level.
All the way across, oh my gosh.
This mall in Chicago wins,
for the coolest fountain.
And probably the number one reason,
why I want you to love laminar flow,
and this is not an exaggeration.
We literally use laminar
flow to protect the integrity
of the moon rocks.
And that is not an exaggeration.
So, I'm about to show you
a clip of how that works,
and if you would like to consider
subscribing to Smarter Every
Day, while we watch this,
this from a future episode.
- Now that we're dressed
in our bunny suits,
we're going to go into our air shower,
and we stay in there for one minute.
And it's a laminar flow,
- [Destin] You have no idea how much,
- it separates between a less
clean area, and a clean area.
- [Destin] You have no idea
how much I like laminar flow.
(laughs)
- [Destin] You don't even know,
I can't even explain it to you.
- You really love it don't you.
(laughs)
- [Destin] I do.
So here we go.
Laminar flow.
Is this going to make our hair fly around?
- No, it's not that kind.
- It's just really slow laminar flow.
- In the meteorite lab, they
have the little tunnels,
that actually would make your hair flow,
they found that stirred up more particles.
So this was designed,
- Turbulence was bad.
- Exactly, yes.
- That's why this is laminar.
- Laminar good, turbulence, bad.
- Got it, I dig it, I like laminar flow.
- That's our minute up.
- Is our minute up?
- Yes.
- [Destin] Our microwave is done.
- [Andrea] So watch your step down.
- I'm watching it, boom.
Wow, alright.
Okay, I hope you enjoyed this video,
I'm going to do what's
called, the soft sell.
I'm just going to give an option to you.
You can either take it or leave it.
I like exploring the world,
using goofy stuff like this.
And I film stuff all over the world,
and I throw it together
in videos like this.
If you would like to consider
subscribing to Smarter Every Day.
It's basically a declaration
for your love of laminar flow,
and low Reynolds Numbers.
That's pretty much what
it is at this point.
So, if you would like to do that,
you may subscribe, if you feel
like this video earned it.
And you could even hit the bell.
If you're not ashamed of it.
So, that's an option for ya.
If you'd like to subscribe
to Smarter Every Day,
you can do that, if not, no big deal.
Thank you to everyone,
who sends me laminar
flow pictures on twitter.
I really enjoy them.
I am Destin, this week, this
video is sponsored by tacos.
I hope you enjoy that
too, have a good one, bye.
- [Destin] What are you doing?
- Making tacos.
This episode of Smarter Every Day,
is sponsored by Hello Fresh.
Which is a meal kit delivery service,
which we use at the Sandlin house,
to cook meals and eat around
the table as a family.
They send food to your house,
and you can just cook per the
recipe, which is enclosed.
They have premeasured
ingredients, it's a great thing.
The reason we like it,
is because it makes everything simple,
and how we do life, in the evenings.
And it let's us eat yummy food.
- [Destin] How do you
know when they're done?
- Timer.
(laughs)
- So if you want to try
this, I highly recommend it.
We love it.
You get really good food, and
your kids learn how to cook.
You can do this by
going to Hellofresh.com,
and use the promo code, smarter80.
For the New Year they have
a special where you can get,
eight free meals basically,
80 dollars off your first
month of Hello Fresh.
Do that by going to HelloFresh.com,
use the promo code smarter80.
Come look at these tacos.
- [Destin] So am I at a taco truck?
- [Boy] Yep.
- [Destin] Nice.
Thanks for making me tacos.
- You're welcome.
- [Destin] Would you rather
have tacos or a haircut?
- Tacos.
(laughs)
- [Destin] Will you get a haircut anyway?
- Yeah.
- [Destin] Okay.
So it works out to about 6.99 a serving,
which is a really good deal.
If you want 80 bucks off your
first month of Hello Fresh,
go to HelloFresh.com and use
the promo code smarter80,
and get 80 bucks off, it's good stuff.
Bye.
If you're mom doesn't love laminar flow,
your mom is wrong.
(laughs)
There's only one thing
left to do, the taste test.
(laughs)
That was laminar flow.
Let's taste turbulent flow now.
Yeah laminar flow is better.
(laughs)